Good evening everybody, and happy Valentine's Day to you.
We were having a little technical difficulty, all my fault.
So we're running a little behind,
but it's actually six 15, so we're starting right on time.
Uh, thank you all for being here.
I was concerned about it being a holiday.
I thought it might just be Steve and I tonight.
And so thank you all for being here.
Um, I think you should get extra credit
for being here on Valentine's Day,
but since we can't give extra credit,
I do have a Valentine candy for you.
If you didn't get a valentine today,
I have candy down here for you.
I was supposed to be handing it out at the back
of the auditorium when you came in,
but we were having technical difficulty, so
I did not make it back there.
But please come and get some now,
after, during, whichever you'd like to do, uh, want
to make that available to you.
Uh, if was anybody not here Sunday?
Okay, one or two, three. Okay. Uh, very good.
Well, my name is Aaron Ferguson.
I'm one of the elders here,
and, uh, had the pleasure of teaching on Sunday,
the Doctrine of Salvation.
And tonight my goal is to just review just briefly
the, the doctrine, the the things I taught on Sunday.
Go into a little more depth on a couple of points
that I couldn't on Sunday.
Uh, I'd like to read another chapter of Ephesians.
We focused on Ephesians two.
I'd like to focus on Ephesians one,
if you brought a Bible tonight.
And then, uh, I have asked
myself 10 questions that are common
salvation questions, and I'm gonna try to answer those.
And then, Lord willing, we'll have time at the end to, uh,
to see if you have any questions.
So we have a lot to cover in an hour.
I'm glad you're here, but I'm gonna do my very best
to cover all of this.
Let me pray for us, and then we will, uh, we'll jump in.
Lord, we're, uh, grateful
to have the opportunity to be here tonight.
Thank you for, uh, the freedom that we have to, uh,
worship together, to study your word together,
to pray together, to be here at church together.
And I pray this is, uh, an encouragement, a time
of encouragement and study.
We're grateful that you didn't leave here.
Leave us here alone.
Uh, but that you left your word to guide us.
And so tonight I just ask that you would use me to clearly
articulate this, uh, very difficult,
complex doctrine of salvation.
It's in Christ and we pray. Amen.
Well, I'm gonna do my best. Like I said,
we have some technical difficulty, so we will
see what happens here.
Uh, when I push a buttons, things are supposed
to go on the screen, so we'll see.
Uh, so far in our series, first things first,
we've been going through essential doctrines
of the Christian faith, and they've
been building on each other.
I love this, that they've been building on each other.
We started with God's revelation.
How has he revealed himself? And then the attributes of God.
Uh, the doctrine of salvation really goes back to
what you believe about God and God's word.
And so you've gotta have a good foundation
of God's revelation.
Do you believe God's word? The Bible is God's word.
Do you believe what God says about himself?
Do you believe about the trinity, the person of Christ?
And then, you know, your salvation
rests on all these things.
So I love how these have built on each other in,
uh, in this series.
Looking forward to the rest of it.
And then Sunday, I shared basically six
salvation questions.
And, uh, these are the, the questions that I asked.
Uh, what is salvation? Who needs to be saved?
Why do we need to be saved? Uh, who does the saving?
How are we saved? And what are the benefits of being saved?
So I'd like to just briefly, especially for those of you all
who weren't here, uh, Sunday, to, to just go speed
through this, uh, that what we did on Sunday.
And then I'm gonna stop
and go a little more slowly through a couple of points,
add some things I couldn't on Sunday,
and then, uh, we'll go on from there.
So very quickly, the first question was,
what is salvation again?
The word salvation means to, to save or to rescue.
And then, uh, Noah Webster defines it.
I love Noah Webster's 1828 dictionary.
If you don't ever use that, I
strongly encourage you to use that.
Uh, dictionary app.
He said, the act of saving or preserving someone from danger
or destruction, saving to save, to rescue.
So this caused me to ask some more questions.
And question number two was, who needs to be saved?
And I pointed out in Ephesians two, three, that we all used
to live in a way that displeased God like the rest
of mankind, meaning we all live in a way
that displeases God, and we all need to be saved.
Salvation is for everyone.
Uh, then we said, uh, we asked the question,
why do we need to be saved?
And I pointed out Paul's, uh, description
of us before salvation.
Without salvation, our condition is hopeless.
We said, Ephesians two, one through three, uh,
Paul says, we are dead in our trespasses and sins.
We follow the prince of the power of the air.
We follow the course of this world.
We are sons of disobedience, and we are children of wrath.
He was describing what we were like before salvation.
Our condition is hopeless.
And so why do we need to be saved? Wrap all that together.
We are displeasing to God, our sinfulness, our,
uh, brokenness.
The fact that we follow
after his enemy, Satan, uh, our condition is hopeless.
We, we, if we aren't saved, we are forever doomed.
And, uh, so made that as clear as I could on Sunday.
Question number three, who does the saving?
Pointed out Ephesians two, four.
But God, God is the one in charge of our salvation.
We're gonna talk more about that tonight.
And, uh, Paul says in Ephesians two 10, we are his work,
not ours, his work.
And so, salvation is entirely a work of God, not anything
that we have done.
Why would he do that? It was the next question,
why would God save us?
Uh, Paul says, it's because he's rich in mercy.
He loved us, and he is gracious towards us.
And so, uh, the New Testament is full
of the love of God towards mankind.
Uh, he did it out of his love and grace
and mercy, very fitting for us to be talking about the love
of God and salvation on Valentine's Day, uh, tonight.
Uh, question number five is why, or,
or excuse me, how are we saved?
And, uh, Paul says, in Ephesians two, eight
and nine, we're saved by grace through faith.
And so again, it's a, it's an act of God.
It's the grace of God that allows us to be saved.
But how does it happen through faith?
And so, um, what is faith is was the question
that we, uh, looked at last, uh, on Sunday.
What is faith? And, um, faith is a trust.
A trust that we put in God's gift of Jesus Christ
for salvation.
Uh, our works don't work.
Uh, I explain briefly why our works don't work.
We are fallen, broken, sinful.
We cannot please God in any way.
And only the, the work of Christ pleases God.
Tonight, I want to dive a little more deeply into that.
Why is that? Why did we have
to be saved by Christ?
And I've put some things on the screen here.
Uh, he was the perfect mediator. He lived a sinless life.
He's going to be our propitiation.
The Bible says, I'll explain in just a minute.
He is our atonement
and his resurrection is going to defeat death.
Uh, so let me dive into those just a little bit more deeply.
Uh, Jesus is our perfect mediator. What does that mean?
Paul says, in one Timothy two, uh, verses five
and six, there's only one God,
and there's a mediator between God and man, only one.
And that is Christ Jesus who gave himself
as a ransom for all.
Why did Christ have to be the one to save us?
He's the perfect mediator.
A mediator is a go between two parties, two parties
that are in conflict,
and the mediator is the person who represents both parties.
And to represent both God
and man, it had to have been someone
who was both God and man.
So if Jesus were 100% man,
he could not have represented us to God.
If he was 100% God, he could not have, uh,
he could not have sympathized with us as human beings.
But since he is the God man, 100% in both
of those at the same time, right?
The hypostatic union, he, it's, he's the perfect mediator
between it's man and God in this salvation covenant.
And so he is, he's perfect for the job.
Uh, God conceived him by the Holy Spirit.
He is born of a woman. He is born human.
We know He's, he's got human attributes,
and yet he's he's fully God.
And so this mediator role that he plays could only be played
by him perfect mediator.
Uh, the Bible says He lived a sinless life
that was absolutely necessary for our salvation.
He had to have lived a sinless life.
Hebrews chapter four, Jesus was in every respect, tempted
as we are, yet without sin.
He was without sin. He was sinless.
Romans by one's man, one man's obedience, Jesus,
the many will be made righteous.
Uh, Jesus had to have lived a sinless life. Why?
Because God could only accept a sinless life
as a sacrifice for the penalty of sin.
And so Jesus had to obey the Father perfectly for God
to accept his sacrifice on our behalf.
So it's absolutely essential to our salvation
that Jesus lived a sinless life.
Very key to the doctrine of salvation.
Uh, Jesus made atonement for our sins.
He was the perfect sacrifice.
Atonement meaning covering up your sin.
Uh, atonement is all over the scriptures.
But Jesus in, uh, Hebrews nine is described this way.
He appeared once for all to put away sin
by the sacrifice of himself.
Again, perfect sacrifice.
He had to be sinless, but he also had to die
because death is the penalty for sin, we said on Sunday.
So Jesus had to die. He had to make an atonement for us.
Uh, Jesus was, and still is our propitiation.
Now, this is a big word, uh, kind of scary theological term,
but Paul uses it.
So we need to know what it is.
A person who is offended is justly,
wrathful, angry.
He's offended. And so there is, uh, there is wrath.
Naturally, when you get offended, you get mad.
The Bible says that sin, uh, angers
or causes God in his holiness to be offended.
And so therefore, wrath is a part
of the penalty here for sin.
But Jesus took away that wrath
with his atonement, his sacrifice.
And so Paul says in fir,
or excuse me, John says, in one John in this is love, not
that we love God, but that he loved us
and sent his son to be the propitiation for our sins.
Jesus atonement, sinless sacrifice, which was essential
for our salvation, also took away God's wrath.
God is no longer wrathful.
He's no longer offended by your sin,
because your sin is no more.
It's been forgiven. It's been covered up
by the atonement of Jesus Christ.
So Jesus is our propitiation, another piece of the
doctrine of salvation that's very, very important.
And then Jesus defeated death with his resurrection.
Um, death of course, is the penalty for sin.
Jesus died in our place, but we still die physically.
And we, uh, are still worried about
that curse of death.
But Jesus being the firstborn from the dead,
defeated the curse of death for us.
And so Paul says, death has been swallowed up in victory.
Death. Where is your sting?
It no longer is something we have to be afraid of anymore,
because in Christ is life, the sting of death is sin.
But thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
So the sting of death, that the curse of death, the penalty
for sin has been erased.
You and I no longer have to fear that death.
Well, let's go on. How are we saved again?
We're saved through faith. That is a put our trust in God.
I use the suitcase illustration on Sunday.
Um, we trust that God is who he says he is.
He has done what he says he has done through his son.
We believe that Christ has done everything we need
to be right with God in salvation.
So we put our faith, we put our trust in the work
of Christ on the cross, uh,
to pay the penalty for our sin.
Uh, the Bible does say that we've got to believe
or receive God's gift.
Many times you'll see this in scripture, John one, to all
who received Christ, who believed in his name,
he gave the right to become children of God.
Uh, John three 16, uh, for God so loved the world
that he gave his only son, that whoever believe in him
believe and receive as part of that, putting your faith in
what God has done for us through Christ.
So it's our response to, uh, his
merciful gift of salvation.
Uh, the last question I answered on Sunday,
and then we'll go on to some new things.
What are the benefits of being saved?
And, uh, I mentioned Sunday that the benefits are endless.
We could spend a year talking about the
benefits of salvation.
So I mentioned three in the verse,
but, uh, if you have your Bibles in Ephesians, chapter one,
we, we read Ephesians two last week or last Sunday.
Uh, but we didn't focus on Ephesians one.
If you have a, your device
or your Bible, Ephesians one,
uh, is phenomenal.
And Paul describes a lot of the benefits
of salvation in Ephesians one.
Now I have Ephesians one, three on the screen,
but, uh, we will read some other parts
of Ephesians one here in just a minute.
Blessed be the God
and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who has blessed us in Christ with every
spiritual blessing.
Another way to say that is who has blessed us with
all the benefits that come with salvation.
And the list is very, very long of the spiritual benefits,
the blessings that Christ has, uh, earned
for us at the cross.
So I mentioned three on Sunday. I wanna mention some others.
I didn't have time to.
Again, we could spend a year of,
of Wednesday nights going over every one of these benefits.
But, um, ke keep reading here with me in Ephesians chapter
one, and then I'll come back to these, uh,
to these benefits.
Uh, verse four, just as he chose us in him
before the foundation of the world,
we're gonna talk about his choosing here in just a minute.
That we would be holy and blameless before him.
There are some benefits in love.
He predestined us to adoption. There's another benefit.
Adoption has sons through Jesus Christ
to himself according to the kind intention of his will,
to the praise of the glory of His grace,
which he freely bestowed on us in the beloved in Him,
we have redemption, another benefit, redemption
through his blood, the forgiveness of our trespasses,
forgiveness, another benefit according to the riches
of his grace, which he lavished on us in all wisdom
and insight he made known to us the mystery of his will,
according to his kind intention, which he purposed in him
with a view to the administration, suitable
to the fullness of the times.
That is the summing up of all things in Christ,
things in heaven, things on the earth.
And in Him, we have obtained an inheritance.
We are heirs as adopted sons.
We have an inheritance is another benefit that we have,
having been predestined according to his purpose,
who works all things
after the counsel of his will to the end.
That we who are first a hope in Christ would be
to the praise of His glory.
And in Him also,
after listening to the message of truth, the gospel
of your salvation, having also believed you were sealed
in Him with the Holy Spirit sealed.
You are sealed by the Holy Spirit. We will talk about that.
Another benefit who is given as a pledge of our inheritance.
He's promised to you.
And the Holy Spirit is keeping you, uh,
until you can inherit what God has for you to inherit
with a view to the redemption of God's own possession,
to the praise of His glory.
Again, we could spend a long time on
the benefits of salvation.
But Jim, just to mention a few generation regeneration,
uh, Jesus says that when you are saved,
you are born again.
You are given a new nature, a new spirit.
The holy spirit's gonna come and live in you,
and you are regenerated.
It's like you've been born again.
And you remember his conversation with Nicodemus.
Nicodemus couldn't quite get his mind around that.
But that's regeneration. It's another benefit.
We we're not dead in our sins and trespasses anymore.
We have new life. Talked a little bit about that on Sunday.
Justification is another one that Paul talks a lot about.
Because of the forgiveness that we have in Christ,
God now sees us not as sinners,
but as sinless.
Remember the great exchange between Christ
and us, God made him who knew no sin, his Son
to become sin for us so
that we might be made the righteousness of God in him.
The big exchange right there, our sinfulness was replaced
with his righteousness.
So when God sees us now, he sees us
as righteous, sinless.
Not that you don't sin in the flesh,
we'll talk about sanctification, but,
but he now sees you through the lens of Christ
and you are justified, meaning, uh, he sees you just
as if you have not sinned.
Justification. It's a, it's a wonderful, uh, benefit
of salvation, reconciliation.
You know what that is? We have been,
our sin has separated us from the fellowship of God.
And now Christ has reconciled that, that relationship,
and we now have fellowship with him again.
Redemption. We've been bought with a price.
We've been, Jesus gave himself as a ransom for us.
We've been redeemed.
We, we've been bought back from the enemy, right?
Uh, Jesus paid for us with his life on the cross.
We've been, we've been redeemed.
Redemption is another, uh, benefit.
We now belong to the Savior, not to, uh, to Satan.
As we were talking about Sunday adoption.
He adopts us as one of his children.
Uh, the Bible calls us, adopted, uh, sons
of God, children of God.
Uh, people who are, uh, sons of God have inheritances.
They are heirs. And so we will inherit everything
that God has ready for us to inherit, uh, someday when we,
uh, go to be with him.
The Holy Spirit is a benefit.
You know, the Holy Spirit indwells those who are believers,
he, uh, left us, went back to heaven,
but he sent the helper to indwell us
and enable us to
live the Christian life the way we should equip us
with spiritual gifts and other things lead us
to truth sanctification.
One of the benefits is
that he is now conforming us into the image
of his son sanctifying us.
He is moving us in a direction where we are starting
to look like and reflect the image of his son.
Now, that doesn't happen perfectly while we're here,
but we will someday be just like him, sinless.
And, um, that's what the end game of sanctification,
which we call glorification.
So you're growing spiritually.
You're becoming more and more like Christ and your attitudes
and your character qualities
and the, you know, the fruits of the spirit are coming out.
And you, you have a desire
to share his good news with other people.
You're being sanctified, made holy in the flesh just
as you are internally.
You are now becoming externally.
And then one day that sanctification,
what's the final chapter is called Glorification.
When sin is No more.
And we are, we take on that glorified body
and we look just like Christ.
And so anyway, these are some of the benefits of salvation.
And, uh, golly, we could talk about a lot more.
But, uh, I wanted to hit on just a few.
Well, let's go on. I have, I was trying to think
of some questions that, um,
regularly come up in conversations about salvation.
And, uh, I wanted to pose these questions
and give you an answer here.
And then, uh, Lord willing, will have time for you
to ask questions as well.
Pardon my voice. I, uh, five times today.
So this is my sixth time to teach,
and I'm hoping it'll last a little bit longer.
Um, alright. And we start talking about salvation.
What about election? What about predestination?
Uh, if you're still there in Ephesians one,
look back at verse four, Ephesians one
and verse four, what about election?
Uh, what about this thing called predestination?
What is election in the first place?
Uh, election is this idea that God, uh,
before the creation of the world, chose those
who would be saved.
And, um, if you look at Ephesians one
and verse four, just as he
chose us in him, thank you so much.
It's kind of you. Just as he, uh, chose us in him
before the foundation of the world, that we would be holy
and blameless before him in love,
he predestined us to adoption.
Okay? Do we believe in election and predestination?
We have to. It's right there in scripture.
And so of course we do.
How do we reconcile this though, with
what we know about salvation?
Skip on down to verse, uh, 11. I forgot to read that one.
Also, we have obtained an inheritance having been
predestined according to his purpose.
Again, predestined. Uh, this is all over the New Testament.
You can't get around.
It's not like as a Christian, you can say,
I don't believe in election or predestination.
Well, it's in scripture. It's a biblical concept.
It's, it's a doctrine itself.
And so, uh, we have to wrestle
with election and predestination.
Uh, here's the, here's the thought
behind election in our sin.
We were dead in our trespasses and sins.
Paul says, Romans chapter three, that no one seeks God.
No one understands, no one is righteous. None.
If that's true, which we believe it is, all
of us are rotten from the beginning.
No one seeks God.
So no one would ever get saved
except God has elected some
to be saved.
He has chosen before time, uh,
for some to be saved.
He has predestined some to be saved.
Listen to these, uh, verses Acts chapter 13,
when the Gentiles heard the gospel,
as many had been appointed to eternal life, believed
Jesus regularly said when he was teaching those
who have an ear here, right?
Those who have an ear pay attention.
Uh, he would, he would teach to a crowd.
But those who have an ear would respond to him.
Not everybody would respond to the gospel, but some would.
Why would those some respond?
Because they had been appointed
before time, not based on any merit of our own, but just
because of God's sovereign choice.
Some would believe Second Thessalonians, we are bound
to give thanks to God for you
because God chose you from the beginning to be saved.
It's all over the New Testament.
So we have to wrestle with this in our minds.
What does that mean? It means what? It says.
God chose before time, some to be saved,
otherwise no one would be saved.
Because no one's gonna choose God out of a rebellious,
sinful, dead heart
unless he wakes them up, right,
regenerates them, and they come to him
because he has chosen them.
So it's a, it's hard to wrap our minds around,
but we have to wrestle with it
because it's right here in Scripture.
Uh, probably the most, well-known passage of this
doctrine is Romans 8 29
and 30 for those whom he God four new.
He also predestined to become conformed
to the image of his son.
Before time he knew some would be saved.
He chose some to be saved. For knew here means he acted.
It's not just he knew who would pick him,
but he actively knew them.
He chose them. He predestined them to be conformed
to his image, the image of his son.
And then those that he chose, who he predestined,
the Bible says, he calls he
who has an ear here, right?
Uh, he calls them and they respond.
And this is whom he called. He justified.
He forgave, he cleansed them as wide as snow.
And these whom he justified, he glorifies.
They, they will become like his son.
Eventually, uh, after, uh, they begin eternal life.
So, okay, this is all over the New Testament.
Uh, just wanna point it out.
Election as Christians, as people who believe the Bible
election is, has got to be one of those doctrines
that we're aware of and believe in because it's biblical
and, uh, doesn't make it easy to understand for sure.
But it's there. We have to, uh, we have to grapple with it.
So, okay, here's a common question.
Why would I share the gospel if God has already
chosen who will be saved?
And I apologize for the, uh,
the text running off the screen there.
We had some technical difficulty, as I was saying,
why do you share the gospel if God's already
chosen some people to be saved?
Well, number one, Jesus told us to share the gospel,
go into all the nations and make disciples.
So we're commanded to share the gospel.
Okay, well, that makes that pretty simple.
And you and I don't know who the chosen are.
So we fish for men, we cast our nets,
we throw out our line.
We don't know who the chosen are. Only God knows that.
And so you and I obey God and we cast our nets
or throw our line in and we fish for men
and the way we're supposed to,
and some will receive the good news and some won't.
We know that to be true,
but we want to be obedient to what the gospel says.
Uh, God wants to use us to reach the chosen.
How will they believe if they have not heard right?
And how will they hear unless somebody goes to them?
He wants to use us as a part of his work
to share the gospel.
And so there are biblical reasons
for why we share the gospel.
Um, does, do we get frustrated when some don't believe?
Maybe, but we probably shouldn't.
We know some will believe and some won't.
Our job is not to, to grab the fish
and pull them into the boat.
Our job is just to throw out the net or to cast our line.
And those whom God has chosen will respond.
So, uh, this really frees us up, share the gospel,
but leave the results up to God.
We, we don't control people's salvation.
Uh, we leave the, the, uh, the catching of the fish to him.
So yes, we should share the gospel.
Uh, even though God has elected some,
uh, if God has elected or chosen
or predestined, whatever word you want to use, doesn't
that override our free will?
What about our free will?
You always hear about our free will? Well, it is true.
God created us with freedom of choice.
You chose to came, come here tonight.
You chose what you ate today.
You chose how, what you put on,
what you chose what to do in your day.
You make choices and there are
consequences for your choices.
But your will is in bondage
before salvation.
Your will is remember, uh, an expression
of your sinful,
imperfect, broken nature.
And so your will,
you might think you have a completely free
will, but you really don't.
It's tainted and spoiled by your sinfulness.
And so your will is really not free at all.
Uh, and if God let you have your way,
you would never choose him.
Right? We, we've already talked about that.
So your will is bound by your sinful nature.
And, and then therefore, we would never choose to be saved.
Um, so again, he has to elect some
because no one would choose Jesus
that we all rebel against him.
So what about your free will?
Well before salvation, your will is not free anyway,
completely free.
You're bound by your sinful nature.
And it's God who raises you from the dead
and takes you out of the darkness and,
and regenerates your heart and gives you the faith.
It's remember, salvation is a work of God, not yours.
His, if he didn't do it, you wouldn't be saved.
So free will. A lot of people want to throw that out there.
But, um,
I think the Bible has a pretty good answer for that.
Will all people be saved?
Here's another question that, that we get a lot.
Uh, first Timothy two, God desires all men to be saved
and come to the knowledge of the truth.
Does that mean all men will be saved? Two Peter three?
God does not wish that any should perish,
but that all should repent.
It sure seems like God, uh, is gonna save all people.
You and I know of course that's not true.
But you look at scripture like that
and you, you think, well, that's inconsistent,
or that contradicts what other scriptures say.
And you have to be really careful here.
Uh, never make a doctrine based on one verse.
That's a really bad idea.
Always take a verse in its context, very close context,
other verses First maybe a chapter, maybe the book
that it's in, uh, maybe the topic that's being discussed.
Take all those things into consideration when you read a
verse like these.
And then maybe even the bigger picture of the New Testament
or the, the Bible as a whole.
So, uh, God desires all men to be saved.
What does the word all mean in this verse? Right?
You have to look at the rest
of the passage verses one through four.
Um, Paul is telling the people here in Ephesus to be praying
for all people, even those in authority,
kings and rulers.
Because God desires all people to be saved.
In other words, all kinds of people to be saved.
We know God did not choose everyone to be saved, right?
Um, only, uh, eight people on the arc,
but everybody else was destroyed, right?
Uh, only four people in, so, you know, Gamora,
Sodom, uh, were saved.
Everybody else was lost.
So not everybody is saved, we know that.
But sometimes when you read these verses you
think, well, wait a minute.
Does God save everybody? No, he does not save everybody.
You have to keep this into context.
So this is not universalism. Everybody is saved.
You see that today, uh, a lot
of universalist churches out there that are, you know,
they preach that everybody gets saved no matter who you are
or where you are, everybody goes to heaven.
And that is not, uh, I don't think biblical at all.
Um, you can't use this verse to support that.
The other verse we were talking about, two Peter three,
nine, will all people be saved?
God does not wish that any should perish,
but that all should repent.
He's talking here again, you gotta look at the context
of the bigger passage verses three through nine.
Again, this is not all people are gonna be saved,
but he's talking about why hasn't Jesus come back yet?
What's taken so long?
And what Peter says is, wait a minute.
He's, he's being patient so that he doesn't wish any
of his elect to perish.
He's waiting for those who he has chosen to,
to come to Christ.
And so be patient, Christ will return when God is ready.
But again, this is not, God is gonna save all people.
Universalism is not a biblical, uh, concept at all.
Are there many ways to be saved? We hear that a lot today.
All paths lead to God.
Uh, we're all saved just in various ways, different ways.
Um, well, that again, is not biblical.
Acts chapter four, verse 12.
There's salvation in no one else but Jesus.
And there's no other name under heaven that has been given
among men by which we must be saved.
There's only one way to be saved according to scripture,
and that's through Jesus Christ.
So there's literally,
I think over 200 verses just in the New Testament that
state that there's only one way to be saved.
And that's Jesus Christ. Okay?
So all paths lead to God,
or all paths lead to salvation is not biblical at all.
Uh, if you look at, uh,
if you look at Christianity from the outside,
people will say, well, you guys, you're just,
you're too exclusive.
They hate the exclusive, uh, nature of Christianity.
There's only one way that's too exclusive.
You're not including everybody.
The exclusivity of Christianity is offensive to people.
There's only one way to be safe.
Well, that's not very kind, right?
That's not very inclusive.
Um, people level that at Christianity all the time.
Here's the problem with that. Every religion is exclusive.
Uh, Islam has a way
to be saved in Islam, right?
Judaism, uh, Buddhism, Hinduism, there's a way to be saved,
and you only can do it this way, right?
So to say that Christianity is exclusive is
a little disingenuous.
All of them are exclusive in some way.
The difference between Christianity is every other religion
is they teach salvation by works.
You've got to do something to earn your salvation.
Christianity is the only religion where salvation is not
by our works, but by the God we worship his work.
So to me, that's a very clear indication
that Christianity is not manmade.
It's not a manmade religion.
This is a, obviously a divine inspiration,
not something men would write.
If we were to write the Bible,
we would save ourselves somehow.
Christianity is, you can't save yourself.
We wouldn't write something like that.
So this is again, to me, indication
that the Bible is not man's word,
but it's God's word is
baptism necessary for salvation.
You might have heard that one.
There are some denominations who believe this is true.
Uh, I'd have to ask you, first of all,
which baptism are you talking about?
New Testament talks about two baptisms of the Holy Spirit
or baptized into the spirit or baptism of water.
And I think most of the time we're talking about external,
uh, baptism by water.
Uh, some, some denominations do include baptism
for salvation.
It's a requirement for salvation.
Uh, we do not believe that is biblical.
To require something like that to be saved would be to,
again, uh, would be a work, something you would do to
be required for salvation.
Something you would do to earn salvation.
And, uh, if you can earn your salvation through baptism,
or if it's a requirement to be baptized
or something else like the Jews circumcised in the New
Testament, uh, then you're, you're basically devaluing
what Jesus has done for us in salvation.
So, uh, baptism, uh, is not a requirement
to, uh, to be saved.
Thank you for the water. That's fantastic.
Uh, almost done here. Question number seven,
how do we maintain our salvation?
Or can we lose our salvation?
Uh, this is a common question.
Uh, Jesus said, I'll give you eternal life,
and they will never perish, ever die.
And no one will snatch them outta my hand.
Uh, he's talking about his sheep here, his followers.
Uh, can we maintain our salvation?
Can we lose our salvation?
I've said several times now,
salvation is entirely a work of God.
If it's a work of God and not of our own, we didn't earn it.
So we cannot lose it.
Uh, we didn't do anything to earn salvation.
Therefore, we can't do anything to lose our salvation.
Uh, God keeps his promises. He says eternal life.
So if he promised you eternal life with salvation,
and he goes, whoops, he just lost his eternal life.
I promised him eternal.
You would have to undo all the benefits.
We just talked about all the benefits.
God says, oh, I'm sorry, you're going back to darkness.
I'm sorry. You're going back to death.
Uh, you'd have to undo all of God's promises to,
to lose your salvation.
And that is not something we see biblically.
Uh, the Lord maintains your salvation, not you.
We read in Ephesians one that he gave you the Holy Spirit.
You're sealed in the spirit.
In other words, you are saved and you will always be saved.
And, uh, there's nothing you can do to lose your salvation.
Okay? But what about Christians who fall away, right?
Christians, we always see Christians rejecting God
or falling away or leaving the faith.
Uh, Jesus says that's gonna happen.
Not everyone who says to me, Lord,
Lord will enter the kingdom of heaven.
In other words, there are a lot of people
who say, Lord, I knew you.
Why don't I get to go to heaven?
And he'll say to them, depart from me. I never knew you.
Uh, in other words, there are a lot of people who claim
to be Christian,
but just claiming to be Christian doesn't mean that you are
indeed a true follower of Christ.
Acting like a Christian going to church, for example,
does not guarantee salvation.
There's a lot of pretenders, I call them false converts,
or people who maybe are acting as wolves among the sheep
who are not believers.
True believers. Can a believer struggle with sin?
Disobedience fall. We say backslide fall away. Absolutely.
Uh, but they will never completely reject Christ.
Um, when Jesus was here, the, the Pharisees said,
he casts out demons in the name of Satan.
And Jesus said, that makes no sense.
If I worked for Satan,
why would I cast demons out of people?
In other words, he says, A house divided against itself
cannot stand.
In other words, why would I work against my own team?
Anyone who has the Holy Spirit in them, the spirit
of God in them, is not gonna reject Jesus Christ.
So if somebody who claims to be Christian leaves the church,
leaves the faith rejects Christ, it's obvious
that they were never first truly a believer.
That's a hard one for us to grasp, but it's true
'cause we all know people who have done that.
So how can I know that I'm saved? Good question.
There's a book of the New Testament written just for you.
First John, if you're doubting your salvation,
first John is just for you.
And the purpose of First John, he says in verse five,
chapter five, verse 13, these things have I written to you
who believe in the name of the Son of God, so that you may
know that you have eternal life.
I wrote this letter so that you may know
that you have eternal life.
And he gives several indications of people
who are saved will act like this.
They will have an assurance of salvation,
and people struggle with whether they're saved.
I get that. Uh, growing up, you know,
every time there was an invitation given in our service,
there was a certain person who would go down
and rededicate their life or get saved again.
What's happening there? Do we have to do that? Uh, do I?
Am I always doubting? No.
The the Bible wants us to make sure that we know for sure
that we are saved.
He don't want us to doubt our salvation.
We can trust God is who he says he is.
And he's done what he says he has done.
So lemme give you just a few things from one John.
Uh, how can I know that I'm saved?
You've trusted Christ for salvation.
Have you put your faith in Christ for salvation,
for forgiveness of sins?
Yes. Okay.
It is assured that you are saved. You're a new person.
You can tell you're not the old self anymore.
You're a new creature growing in Christ.
Uh, you're indwelled by the Holy Spirit.
You love the Lord John says, and you love his people.
You love his church. And you don't practice sin.
Sin doesn't reign in your life anymore
'cause you've overcome it through Christ.
And so these are some of the indications
that you are indeed saved.
Finally, uh, how do I share the plan of salvation?
You may be asking yourself
that this is such a complicated, uh, doctrine.
How do I share it with someone else? Uh, it is complicated.
There's no doubt. It's some of it's hard to understand,
but it's a very simple message.
It's a very simple message.
You are a sinner and you cannot save yourself.
Only God can save you. And he does it through Jesus Christ.
It's not that hard to share the gospel.
Now, several years ago, we went
through a book called What is the Gospel?
Y'all may remember this if you were here then.
And, and, uh, the author gives us four kind of hooks
to remember for sharing the gospel.
God, man, Christ in response. Anybody here?
When we did that, that was, I forget what year that was,
but that was outstanding.
One of my favorite, uh, books, God, man, Christ response.
God, you, you're talking to somebody.
You just talk to 'em about God first, not you don't jump
to Christ, just God and the attributes of God.
We believe that God created the heavens
and the earth, everything, including you and me.
And he is sovereign. He's in charge. He makes the rules.
He is holy and righteous and sinless.
You just described what the Bible says
about God's attributes.
We just, we just went through God's attributes
and he made man kind in the image of God.
Therefore, we are valuable and we have purpose
and dignity in life, but we rebelled against God
and we sinned against him.
And we've inherited the sinful nature
and we're broken and imperfect.
No one's gonna say they're perfect.
Everybody's gonna say, uh, uh, admit that they're imperfect
unless you ask 'em, are you a good person?
Nobody seems to know the answer to that.
But they always say, yes, I'm a good person.
Have you ever told a lie? Oh, well, sure I have.
Have you ever stolen anything? Well, yeah. Okay.
So you're not a good person.
You have to kind of maybe show them some a little bit
that they're not perfect.
But we all, I think we all
understand that we're not perfect.
God, man. What do we do?
How, how do we reconcile our relationship with God?
You talk about Christ and his attributes.
He's sinless and he was the God man, and,
and he died for our sins on the cross.
You talked about the sacrifice
and the forgiveness that he offers.
And all you have to do is receive that gift, right?
Receive that luggage that we talked about.
Put your faith in Christ. You can do this.
This is, don't worry about all the intricate doc,
the the other tangents that I just took, uh,
regarding the doctrine of salvation.
Uh, keep it very, very simple.
And then God will do the rest. Um, what if they reject me?
What if they turn me down again?
Our job is to fish for men.
It's not to grab the fish and strangle them
and bring them into the boat.
Uh, we fish and let God do the rest.
And if they reject you, okay.
Share the gospel with somebody else.
Some will respond, some won't.
Alright, that was a lot of information,
but we have, uh, just a few minutes here.
I'd love to see, uh,
what questions have come to mind for you.
And if not, I will pray us out and we will get outta here.
But, uh, anything come to mind just
during this, uh, during this time,
I wanted to mention, uh,
Aaron was talking about sharing the gospel.
I wanted to have some evangelism training beginning on,
uh, February 26th.
There are four classes, um, seven to 8:00 PM
Topics are what is evangelism?
Um, sharing the gospel at work, sharing the gospel of school
and sharing the gospel with Muslims.
And so that's an opportunity beginning on February 26th, uh,
once a month put on by our admissions team. So,
Very good. Mentioned that.
And, uh, also, uh, on our website,
under the, uh, category of resources, there is a very, um,
excellent, um, information on, uh, the gospel,
uh, along with, uh, uh, a video, uh,
titled The Three Circles.
And then it talks about, uh, god, uh, man, uh, Christ
and response, which Aaron just went over.
So there are resources available, uh, that would provide,
um, some information about how to share the gospel.
So just wanna mention that. So
Thank you, Steve.
Steve, you can join me up here
for stay down there and whichever you wanna do.
Uh, Victor question,
Aaron.
Um, thanks for all that explanation.
I've always had trouble understanding in Matthew 13,
the parables of the sower, where it says, um,
when anyone hears the word of the kingdom
and does not understand it, the evil one comes
and snatches away what has been sewn in his heart.
That is what, this is what was sewn along the path.
And for what was sewn on rocky ground.
This is the one who hears the word
and immediately receives it with the joy.
Yet he has no root in himself, but endures for a while.
And when tribulation or persecution arise on account
of the word, immediately, he falls away.
And then he talks about the thorns.
This is one who hears the word, but the cares of the world
and deceitfulness of riches choke the word
and proves it unfruitful.
And then lastly, what is so on good soul?
That is the one who hears the word and understands it.
So I'm, I've never understood when we talk about the elect,
if those people who fell away
after hearing what happened if,
if you considered them not chosen,
and they heard they wanted to believe,
but I don't know, can you reconcile that for us?
Yeah. Those are different responses to, to God's word,
to the gospel.
And Jesus is describing these various responses.
And so, again, we don't know, at least I don't know who
is who, whom God has chosen.
So we do cast the seed,
but there's gonna be various responses.
We all know people who today may not be saved
or, uh, a a genuine believer,
but they may have gotten excited about church at one time,
or they were reading their Bible, or they heard the message
and they were so excited at camp.
All these kinds of things, they, they, uh, the Bible says,
tasted this good news, but it never took root.
And so, um, again, we, we, we have to believe
that God has his purposes here,
but these are various responses to the, the good news.
And, uh, I, I have to trust
that God has his purposes for who that is and,
and who responds and who doesn't.
So good, good question.
I have friends that, you know,
got excited at camp just like I did.
I gave my life to Christ, but, and they were so excited,
but then they just kind of died off, uh, that, that, that,
uh, excitement died off,
and they never did follow through.
What, what was the deal? The enemy came
and stole their, you know, choked out their seed,
choked out their plant.
Perhaps they weren't, it wasn't their time.
Perhaps they weren't meant to be a believer, I don't know.
But, um, I think that's what Jesus is describing there.
Steve, anything else you wanna add to
that? I think that's a great question.
Very similar experience at camp.
I was saved at Falls Creek, uh, church camp.
And, um, I just go back
and think about that 50 a long time ago.
And, uh, I think about friends that, that, uh, close friends
that walked the aisle, and there was a lot of emotions.
And now as I think back about our lives
and how our pasts have crossed from time to time, I
remember them making a decision and wondering, okay, was
that how, how has their life turned out differently?
And what do they really believe now? So happens? Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, yes ma'am. Yeah.
Um, so mine has to do with, um, the question,
can Christians fall away?
And I agree that the idea of falling away doesn't seem
to fit with the imagery that's used in salvation,
we're made alive in Christ, we are born again.
But there are, um, denominations that they have some verses
that they claim don't seem to fit with the idea that, well,
if they fell away, then they were never saved to begin with.
Um, ones like Hebrews 10, 26
through 27 saying, for if we go on sinning deliberately
after receiving the knowledge of the truth,
there no longer remains a sacrifice for sins,
but a fearful expectation of judgment
and a fury of fire that will consume the adversaries.
Um, first Timothy 18 through 19, uh,
Paul is talking to Timothy about holding the faith
and good conscience,
and that by rejecting this, um,
have made a shipwreck of their faith.
Uh, he says in Galatians five, four, talking to those
who were trying to enforce the law
and circumcision in order to be saved, saying
that you have been severed from Christ who you,
who would've been justified by the law,
you have fallen away from grace.
And then they'll also bring up examples like
how the Spirit came on Saul in the Old Testament,
and then it left him.
So the question is, how do we reconcile those verses
with the idea that our salvation still can't be lost?
Yeah, those are great questions.
Uh, the Old Testament, the Holy Spirit, uh,
acted differently in the Old Testament.
Saul, you brought up Saul, then he does in the New Testament
and dwells believers continually.
We, we know that, uh,
but he did not do that in the Old Testament.
He indwelled and left and in dwelled and left. Mm-Hmm.
And so, um, Saul is not a good example there to bring up,
uh, regarding the s doctrine of salvation.
You have to keep in mind, Hebrews is written to,
Hebrews is written to Jews, Christians who were Jewish,
struggling with, uh, Judaism, how do they reconcile Judaism,
you know, judaistic rituals
and things with what Christ has done.
And so the writer is trying to explain to them, uh, the,
you know, how do you deal with the ritual of circumcision
or the rituals of, you know, Sabbath
or sacrificing and all that.
So, uh,
what he's talking about there is you've got this gospel
that frees you from all these things.
Don't forsake this for this. Does that make sense?
So again, you gotta look at the context of the verses,
the passages, the book, the reason why it was written.
Uh, so yeah, I, I see what they say, what they're meaning
by, you know, it appears that Christians can fall away, the,
the, uh, but the, the context that the, the,
the bigger picture here is we know that
it's not ours to lose.
We, we didn't do anything to earn it.
So it's not ours to lose.
God is faithful and he'll hold onto his own.
So why would he elect some and then say, oops, I lost him.
You know what I mean? So we, we trust,
we put our trust in God for, um,
per preserving those that he has elected.
Hope that makes sense. Mm-Hmm.
Steve, any, anything else there? Okay, good question.
Really good question. One more, maybe. Yeah, one more.
We gotta pray and get outta here.
Okay. Um, so you kind of hit on my question
with your last slide a little bit,
but I'm hoping you can maybe
give a little more clarification.
Okay. Or just help me understand.
So, um, the relationship really
between these foundational big rock issues
that we've been talking about and our, like, our salvation.
So here's kinda my question is, is our salvation as simple
as repentance of our sin and belief in Jesus as our savior?
Or are these foundational big rocks also necessary knowledge
for our salvation?
And so let me just explain real quick
kind of like what I mean by that.
If you're not tracking, so like some people have kind
of summarized this idea, uh, with belief in versus belief
that, and so like in, um, James two 19, it says, you believe
that God is one, you do well, right?
Uh, even the demons believe in shudder, right?
And so we know that even the demons believe in attributes
of God, that God is one.
Obviously it's not a, a saving faith.
And so then when I look at like my own life,
I look back at when God saved me.
I don't think I could have articulated salvation by works
or, you know, all the attributes of God, right?
Um, and so just kinda to repeat my question, um,
so is our salvation as simple as repent of our sin
and believe in Jesus as our savior?
Um, or are these foundational big rocks
also necessary knowledge?
Do we have to believe that they are true to be saved?
That's a great question. You, you nailed it. It's simple.
Uh, faith in Christ, repentance of sin,
faith in Christ, you're saved.
I don't think, I mean, Jews believe there's a
God, they believe in God.
Maybe not the God that we believe necessarily,
but a lot of people believe in God,
but don't put their faith in Christ.
So, uh, I think the knowledge
of all these doctrines will come later.
Think about a child, a child doesn't understand all these
doctrines, but they can put their faith in Christ that God,
their sinners, and God has saved them through Christ.
So I think I, you nailed it.
I think absolutely you can come to the Lord in faith,
asking forgiveness of sin without understanding all the
intricacies of the doctrines.
Yeah, absolutely. Steve, anything you wanna
A hundred percent. That was really
Good. Good
question. Okay.
We'll be down front if you have any other questions.
Thank you all so much for being here.
I'm gonna ask Steve to close this in a word of prayer.
And happy Valentine's Day.
Gracious, heavenly Father, we're so blessed
to have the opportunity
and privilege to gather together this evening.
I thank you for each person here
and for their commitment to, uh, to hear your word,
to study your word, to, uh, just to know these truths.
Uh, there are many that we wrestle with.
Uh, there are many that we struggle with, uh,
but we place our faith in our Lord Jesus Christ.
We trust you, Lord.
I thank you for Aaron and for his, uh, skills and,
and ability to present this material so well.
And so, uh, in a,
in a manner in which we can understand him, uh, I thank you
for, uh, for his study and his preparation.
Lord, I pray now that you'll be with each person here.
I pray for those that we know that are struggling
with health and other issues.
I pray for those that we know that are in the hospital
and that, uh, those who have, uh, recently lost loved ones.
Lord, I pray for encouragement, uh,
and I pray that you will just watch over us.
Give us a good rest of the evening.
Uh, guide us and direct us. In your name we pray. Amen.
Amen.